just part your lips that's gorgeous yeah
that's stunning holiday fun we hold it
we just turn your body towards me bit
more yeah bit more
gorgeous I get that turn your face
towards me till bit more now this way
pension down let's hit that move all
right who's your daddy okay
sana I know you're her daddy I just I
just want a big big cup
okay look into your man dolly turn your
face this way actually just chin down
and close your eyes and snuggle up to
him and keep looking this way mate and
once again tilt your head just a bit of
way off that sign behind you keep moving
this way keep kicks up beautiful guys
this is why our second wedding a little
lot from last week so I'm hoping today
okay
elevator now ah looks good that's cool
that's perfect
all right guys you guys keep on talking
shoot while we talk about us here so
I'll get you the background just look
back at yourself right that's it chin
down a bit
that's good how they hold it what you
need to do just obviously safely about
here let's go back a bit that's it at it
not keep looking up that way
okay what are we to do I want you go
hahahaha exactly even if you make this
sound I think it helps the expression
there give me a second hold on a second
one two go for it no no no no that is
too happy it's too happy
I want it like I want it evil I want to
so I want it yeah you go there you go
ready run go bigger I want you to turn
your hips I want you you're actually
sitting on your hip more than that's
better
and then
I show no flash
okay very gently with this hand just
want you to hold it here for me that's
it and just bring you a fishbowl Bell
that's beautiful and chin up a little
bit until your face or too much just a
bunch it up again beautiful that move
eyes are my handies
just say just there I bet again
I'll come ahead of you and that's it
just a beautiful Oh
yeah face me perfectly that's it to
there
I want you to hold his hand again and
pick up the dress I like your red to
walk with it that's it that's it the
move and now bring your back board
towards inmate if you can that's it and
bring your lip your right foot back a
bit again but swapping over your left so
I can't I can see a gap into a bit more
the other way that's it Oh too much just
back a bit ok now look back at your man
darling and look at your wife milk mate
hold the beer
just lucky your lips on his top lip I
think it's quite beautiful more than the
other one anta like that now but turn
towards me that this way that's better
just there
yes that's it that's the shot
good you guys how do they hold it all
the day
Oh there
just sit down watch it turn around and
face that way and start by putting one
leg over and they come back a few steps
I want you to rest on your back and your
elbows now yeah if you need to put your
legs up which might be quite dequeued
actually you can cross your ankles over
what I'm going to get you to do
imma need you to put your chin up all
the way and then the lights going to
shine but we'll do it last minute so you
won't get a cramp I need you about that
far away get the glow on her face I know
it's not easy to be photographed by me
but it's worth it keep your hands out
really free just breathe through your
mouth really fill this win by slide off
your amazing lips it beautiful beautiful
beautiful I don't know what to look at
first I've been sort of sit right back
your backside right in there that's it I
just bring one foot underneath the other
that's it so what one foot flat and one
knee up so you've sort of got one
someone's like that on the ground okay
that's it that's it that's it and bring
it bring your heel more underneath
that's it cool and bring this hand a bit
more in that's it good and that want to
be more in there you go that move and
just looking at to the right a bit mate
let's see this caught that's a good
okay never press your boobs against a
glass not all ain't jacking on I just
wanted to see it I wasn't take a photo
of it that's beautiful I'll believe I'm
diving human all right just just a handy
has to get a cramp because I want to
fall in literally yeah all right so you
just bend your elbows out darling bend
your elbows up just lets you point your
toe towards me a little bit then see it
beautiful let's board is now turn your
face to the right that's right champ
gorgeous you
that's beautiful what there this point
really quickly just here
soft central guys breathe through your
mouth breathe through your mouth a
really obvious part in your lips I lead
the back that's hilt just work your way
to a squid darling
just look thats better that's better
Archie bags with your right hand now
what you to do just sort of bring it
over see ya yeah that does that do again
that's nice
okay look where's
Oh
my eyes down don't it
that's also out of it
yeah okay give me a go all the lame lame
give me a barman alright you're looking
very good very very nice yes we just
ladies not to give them some good you
know like them well now I want you to
look at each other and cry
uncontrollably just separate your bodies
a little bit just the other bodies let's
go don't move guys more profile just
that's it
holla die
Just Breathe three mouths just really
subtle therefore we do beautiful health
there
it's touching up a bit I'm a bit higher
talking to the light and you don't come
down darling chin down
that's it turn your face to the right
there and Nikki
into into her two edges of it that's it
beautiful and eyes down with laughing
hysterically that's it let's throw it
behind you darling on the count of three
throw it behind you and look at it as it
travels in the air ready one two go for
it
love that guys keep on going almost
there
you
you
you